being a part of a computer science
program with near equality or like near
equitable representation of men and
women has been an amazing experience I
think that while everyone within the
school of computer science has been
incredibly supportive and there's a
great spirit of collaboration there's
just something special to be said about
having role models and peers that look
like you and then have relatable
experiences that you've also had that
can connect you to opportunities
specifically for women and can that are
just a lot of fun to be around meeting
current upperclassmen who were school
computer science majors hearing about
how great their experience had been
everything from the spirit of
collaboration that they had been
experiencing the support from teaching
assistants from their professors and how
they really felt like this was a place
that they could thrive I really felt
that it was somewhere where I could grow
and thrive as well one person that's had
a really large impact on me in my time
with the school computer science has
been my academic adviser professor
Stella
he also co taught a course that I ate
for my sophomore year
he's just been someone who I've been
able to turn to not only with help
navigating the school computer science
picking courses trying to understand
what opportunities within SES are the
best fit for me but he's also been there
to help me with everything from personal
problems to career decisions through
connecting me to alumni and just
encouraging me and supporting me to be
the best version of myself that I can be
so with my computer science education
the only thing that I'm completely
confident about right now because I
think there are a lot of different ways
that I can take it but I know that I and
this is a little cheesy but I want to
help make the world a better place I
care a lot about the intersection of
computer science and social good and
using the skill set that I'm genuinely
privileged to have to try to impact
in a meaningful way I don't know what
that looks like yet but I'm excited to
figure it out